Maggie counts with this foot.
Basically, the first time I said, "Maggie, how many is this honey?"
And that's it! Good!
Sit down, good!
And then, I realized I didn't even have to use fingers.
I could just ask her.
So I said like, "Maggie what's two times three?"
Perfect!
It's perfect!
She gets a little treat for that. Good.
And then, maybe one of you would?
I would love to.
Maggie, no, Maggie?
Magpie, what's eight minus two?
Eight minus two?
Yes.
Wow!
Good girl. Sit down. Good.
Would you like to ask her one as well?
Sure.
Maggie, listen up.
What is the capital of Alabama?
How about an addition question?
Okay.
Alright.
Maggie, three plus three?
Everybody says the answer is six, do you think this is a trick?
That's good.
Something other than six isn't an answer so...
Maggie, two times four?
That's a tough one.